all right welcome back today I have son
Dib with me son dip is a developer
advocate what is a developer advocate do
yes so developer advocates at Google and
I think at a lot of other places are
engineers who get to engage with the
community so they get to participate by
speaking at conferences writing like
cool documentation code samples
basically giving back and also learning
from the community like developers and
operators and using that to improve
product I say so they're not like
marketing people no it's it's very much
intended to be like you know engineers
who have come from that ecosystem or
that environment so former developers
operators specifically within kubernetes
like you know definitely cluster
operators you know sis admin's DevOps
those kinds of folks that kind of
background awesome so what exactly does
a developer advocate do in the
kubernetes ecosystem well yeah things
are you involved in yeah it's a great
question so I named is sort of funny
because I think developer advocate
implies developer only when really
within the kubernetes ecosystem its
developer DevOps pure ops and kind of
further and further down the sack so
with within the cooperate ecosystem I
think people are getting to participate
by one helping build like better you
know kind of code samples around just
using kubernetes for operators but also
going further and further up to stack
with new projects and tools that are
very developer centric which kubernetes
by itself is not a developer facing tool
in a lot of ways awesome so like walk me
through an average day for you yeah so
uh a lot of it really is well one
non-stop email checking and group chat
participation and then you know filing
bug reports on products that are part of
Google Cloud writing code samples
writing documentation updating code
samples and documentation because those
get out of date very quickly and
answering PRS on github and helping
merge and new code so I'm sure everyone
is dying to know how many slack channels
are your apart oh that's a number I will
never share publicly cuz it would
frighten and confuse most people so you
said you work a lot with the ecosystem
like what are some really exciting it
goes to some tools and and kind of
patterns that are emerging that you're
excited about personally yeah no I mean
I think what's really cool is I was at
the first
coop
back in 2015 when it was 300 people in
one room in the Palace Hotel
and it's grown incredibly since that
time in luck the last three and a half
years and what's really cool is it's
gone further and further up so we're
getting closer and closer to like end
application developer so I'm really
excited about the things that make
application developers lives easier so
some of the really cool tools a little
bit self-serving because they're Google
tools that we're working on but like I
think scaffold and jib are really cool
tools I think and then something like a
native which isn't exactly developer
facing but it's a project which is gonna
make it easier for application
developers to get a lot of these cool
benefits without having to write you
know
yamo and remember V 1 beta 1 or if you
want alpha 1 ap is exactly so let's say
I'm new to the kubernetes community
right you said 300 we're like what 8,000
load this conference the community is
growing dramatically if I'm new to this
thing where do I start where are some
areas that I can make an impact maybe
even if I don't have a background in
software or or computer science yeah you
know everybody has a unique experience
to bring which is what I found and just
hearing talks from across you know the
community today in the last couple days
at coop con everybody's got something
compelling to share I think you know
there's tons of getting started
resources out there but there's not as
there's never enough like applied use
case so taking your experience that
you've had even if it was without
kubernetes and saying well how would I
map that to kubernetes environment or
you know an environment with you co or
with any of the other thousands of tools
that are out there you know rethinking
through that and then sharing that story
is still pretty valuable because I think
it helps everybody trying to map
something new in their brain I just went
to a session that was about PCI
compliance right so processing credit
card data something we've been doing for
years and other in traditional
environments but not as much in
kubernetes and that's really valuable
for the community to learn awesome so
share stories yeah exactly share stories
and and it doesn't have to be code it
doesn't have to be an innovative thing
it just has to be something that's I
think positive and helping move the
community forward and that could just be
a simple thing that you've learned that
you want to share awesome well thank you
son dip all right thank you
[Music]